[Music]
absolute
uh what a ladwell said I'm lucky enough
to be joined by one of the all-time
great midfielders he's a canopy rugby
Legend who has won seven NPC titles he's
also managed to rack up 152 Super Rugby
games with the mighty Crusaders winning
three titles along the way he's also won
five rugby championships with the All
Blacks and has just recently returned
from Japan having won the top league
with the Kubota Spears he is a true
winner and off the field is the ultimate
lad a man who everyone speaks extremely
highly of for good reason he is of
course the lad the legend Ryan karate
welcome mate
[Laughter]
[Music]
intro was almost too far away for me to
read so I was I was really squinting to
read it but like we got through there in
right what a what an honor to have you
on the podcast oh thanks for having me
on I was uh I was waiting for the call
up and
yeah that's the only reason I came and
helped train because I thought I'd get a
chance to jump on so it has worked out
so well having you come train mate how's
it been coming back in
um an ex-crusader Legend future Hall of
Famer I believe coming back in and just
checking the boots on and having a run
around my awesome so good to just see
the boys and Connor
yeah mainly just to see everyone but
also like I guess the last few years
overseas you kind of
you kind of forget how good it is and
you kind of I guess you you talked about
Kubota like
so much of
that environment you're like oh the
Crusaders would do this and the ABS
would do this and you kind of it's nice
to see how Justified that is because it
is so so good in here and as well just
so good to see the boys like like
so many good connections and friendships
you know forged over heaps and heaps of
games so and to reconnect with those
guys and just just come in and be in a
changing room again is awesome you must
have some good memories in that changing
room oh so good a lot cleaner without
Israel
way tighter but um yeah just oh locker
room chat how good yeah and you
mentioned Kubota you've been over in
Japan has it been five years you've been
over there you're in after 2019 so yeah
four seasons over there yeah man goes
quick eh yeah yeah real fast but so good
to be home you're just going winter the
winter probably glow in the dark
also be back for another Christchurch
winter and how did you find it over
there oh awesome yeah awesome yeah like
so cool so much to love about Japan and
the people and the culture and stuff and
and the footy can be frustrating at
times but it's still just it's awesome
it's a great opportunity to get over
there and experience something new and
um yeah I loved it I really really
enjoyed it and went out on a winning
night mate Kubota Kubota Spears winning
the competition but you would have
thought that was going to be possible
when you signed or did you oh I knew it
would be tough it was real it was real
like um
some big learnings like yeah like we
were kind of on they're on the right
trajectory when a few of us kind of got
there and
um probably credit everyone there they
like a Japanese group with a really open
mindset to growth and
able to take learnings from here and try
and apply them with that environment was
was we're really lucky because a lot of
teams aren't quite like that yeah yeah
so it was it was awesome and we had a
great group
um I thought each year we got a little
bit better I think we started their
first year we're kind of mid-table then
we finished fourth and third and then we
made the final and started beating teams
that we'd never been before and I think
that group just really believed and we
had a really awesome culture for that
kind of fourth year that was really kind
of it was a really great great really
special kind of cool environment and um
I think I think culture is the most
important part of it you know any rugby
team and we got that right and I think
that um that helped us get there
get the win in the end so it was pretty
cool did you have the same Foreigners
for the sort of four-year period yeah
like me myself Foley got there at the
same time as well as a guy David
bulbring and father know he had a weirdo
was there as well and we had a really
good group and then I like we're on both
though so we're pretty kind of safer
dominated because yeah safer Coach and
he's a good rooster and then um Malcolm
Marx came in and he's basically a whole
front row in Japan so our scrum started
dominating and
um yeah just everyone just got along
really well a lot of golf you know a few
beers every now and then flying the
drink oh love it love it love a feed out
like yeah lots of good spots and take
care so yeah it was um it was a great
four years in Kuwait to finish up yeah
and I guess a lot of players would go
over they always get frustrated that
especially of your caliber that they
don't have much say on the rugby or um
you know they have these ideas but they
always just get brushed down or you
can't get them across the line but
sounds like you had a little bit more
say than most yeah like you talk to guys
at other teams and you can kind of you
have the same kind of conversation
everyone's kind of facing the same yeah
kind of challenges and so like yeah
talking to like I think Ben Finnell for
example he was over there and he's
trying to do some stuff defensively that
you'd worked back here and then I just
remember his frustration and not being
able to you know get in your Headway
yeah with um introducing that so it made
me feel like really grateful that we had
the opportunity to be able to give
because to be able to give his you know
massive part of just being happy right
you know being able to give and help and
that was it was really kind of rewarding
and then you got Bernard doing a lot of
attack stuff and
um Malcolm helping out and everyone just
have an input and then once you go to
kind of team that's being driven by the
players and everyone's like right on
board and everyone's so invested so it
was um it was cool and it's cool to see
how much it means to guys that kind of
it's a different age
um Japanese rugby like a company is
you're kind of a
I guess a marketing tool for the company
yeah it's quite it's quite strange but
those guys will be Kubota for Life
they'll go to the factory and work and
then come to training and you you see
them turn up in their overalls and
you're like
so your players were still working
during season
some of them yeah we all think a little
bit that's crazy yeah 40 were Pro and I
arrest were all workers so they'll go to
the takeaway office and some of them in
sales some of them are literally we
train on like a factory there's like a
Rugby field in the middle of like sure
they do it yeah so like tractors driving
past all sorts so
um
yeah it was it was it was different
different experience yeah and so was it
your decision to finish there or how did
it all end up had you had enough yeah it
just got bit like um so we've got
Madison who's just turned one and my
other daughter Grace who's two and a
half so it was just my wife Terry she
didn't come back this season just with
two young ones it was just a little bit
hard the language and and the travel
back and forth so she was more
comfortable saying in Christchurch with
we've got both our parents and support
so yeah
yeah and they're just kind of at that
age now it's just too hard to be away so
yeah it was definitely definitely Keen
to back get back home and
spend more time changing nappies and
getting up early no wonder you're eating
out every night over there yeah cook to
save yourself
oh I know it says heat Em Up ramens or
those two-minute rice
yeah well you can't do it otherwise
you're just so lonely yeah you know it's
like yeah so I was pretty lucky it was
we had a good group of lads always to
kind of connect with and so you don't
spend too much time yeah you know yeah
on your own well literally when you go
to the supermarket and you get all the
ingredients to go home and cook
something it's more admin more cost
probably than even just
jumping down the road to away Ramen
joint no that's what I told myself this
way so I convinced myself it's cheaper
to get you know get out for feed and to
cook it out yourself and then you've got
to do dishes as well so
so what's the plan now you have um what
do you what have you come into
mate I'm just literally hardly thought
about it hey a free agent yeah it was
just kind of
oh there's a bit up near but I kind of
just thought hey look if I just focus on
doing the best job I can for Kubota and
fully invest in here then whatever
happens happens and I'm going home to be
with the girls and that's that's the
most important thing so that's kind of
what's happened and then I found myself
day two walking down for a coffee
um just around the corner and I'll see
you drive past the next thing you know
the phone anyway you're coming and hold
a pair for it so
it was literally it was quite weird like
you kind of your whole career you're
like I just
kind of want to be you know I kind of do
whatever you want yeah you get it and
you're like wow this is strange like an
engine too much yeah yeah so it was a
real blessing to I'll stake to you you
reached out and was yeah I was thinking
I was in pretty much straight away yeah
mate yeah I use the fastest response
like you literally ran straight to
training from that message geez that was
quick
yeah so he just I love it I've been part
of a team yeah like you know a lot of um
that's that side of rugby you know the
friendships and the connections and
things like that so yeah I guess I'm
just waiting to see what happens
um definitely not ready to retire then
no you've got plenty more to give your
body's in good neck yeah it's hanging
Japan was was different yeah it's a lot
I guess they train as hard as the games
that's the thing you've got to kind of
if you can be smart around your training
load the games don't take uh they're
fast but they're not as physical as they
are in New Zealand yeah any stretch so
yeah that's the con it was a real
positive and
yeah body held up held up well and
you do you do miss you Miss how good
like the physios and you see the guys
getting managed here you see that's like
that's the gold standard yeah you don't
like go to Japan and from being really
well managed here and it's like hey look
training twice on a Tuesday twice on a
Thursday full contact you're like are
you sure so it's kind of was like it's a
bit of wake up call yeah I remember
getting my um ankle strap for the first
time over in Japan and I rolled it twice
with the streaming also this is a waste
of time mate
oh no
so what's the sort of dream like what
what would you love to what would you
love your next step to be
oh man I just I haven't really thought
about it like yeah
and just just literally just taking it
one day at a time yeah
talking to my manager and seeing like
what opportunities are there which is
which is pretty cool
um
but you may just just just spending time
with the girls yeah like and it's
and it's kind of it's almost been okay
with not having a plan but been okay
like just to to take your time and and
choose and speak to you and what she
what we think is best for our family
next so it's nice I guess that's the
kind of struggle like well not struggle
just being okay with
like not having a plant yeah right so
that's um that's pretty hard for a
yellow Dot
so would you take them overseas would
you take move the family would they be
open to moving or ideally somewhere here
or yeah and New Zealand well ideally
something here in New Zealand like it's
been you've been away for four years
like home's so good so yeah ideally but
then if Terry was open to to going
somewhere overseas and we'd look at that
as well so yeah whatever we do as long
as it's together then that's the main
thing right it's a mate that's a plan
exciting times ahead looking forward to
seeing where you go it could be the red
and black who knows that would be very
cool but I am interested in hearing the
story from the start my first memory of
you was obviously Shirley boys I'd heard
massive raps about the future all back
starting at 10. I was playing ten that
day and I remember thinking oh mate this
this guy is going to be good and gee
whiz you were good but I am Keen to hear
it before that so going back I think
you're born in Nelson weren't you well
one of Nelson's finest yeah I was born
Nelson mum and dad used to live up there
me and my brother were born
um up in Nelson so yeah that's jeez
oh yeah came up I came down the road and
um yeah then my trade out at Brighton
started there with uh when I was five
years old without our phones oh yeah
yeah mate we eat it on the same
five-year-old team yeah yeah we played
pretty much from when we were five
straight right through to when we're
about 13. oh wow yeah so that's pretty
cool so yeah we lived out that's out on
the east side and yeah so it came
through the Brighton ranks and yeah went
off to Shirley and then went back to
Brighton afterwards but of course you
remember the the Shirley Nelson guys
because we never used to be here all
right we couldn't make this that one
semi-final there I think you guys are
the hot favorite so it still hurts
honestly like we'll get together and
we'll still talk about that game I can't
believe oh we had a gun that was like
2005a yeah
man we had a good team mate yeah we're
just funny we're in the Midfield or 10
12 or something yeah
he was on Railway he was so good yeah we
had everyone had a real kind of sweet
spot that year of guys kind of played
the year before and
but we might we just lost the boys high
on full time uh at one point it was the
only game we lost and then
and with you guys in the Simeon fire out
my egos has got us it was oh it's it
like still hurts I can see it we got
pumped by Christchurch boys if you want
to say we're stacked they were so sick
though yeah and they'll still tell you
about it how stacked they were yeah just
catch up with slavery Billy you know oh
have a good time like how could a score
rugby yeah
um that's probably as close as you kind
of get to professional rugby a like just
kind of being with your mates all day
and then go to training and then you
play games kind of that's pretty cool
Connor Connor
ask it's just a really cool time when
you're when you're playing footy age
which is with your mates and doing what
you love when did you know you were you
were going to be good at footy like what
age did you realize that you were pretty
gifted at it
oh then I was I was always really
competitive growing up yeah not really
competitive I remember telling I think
it might have been a primary school so I
don't know how old I was but I remember
telling my mate's mum that I was going
to be in all back one day I just I don't
know she must have told me before he
paid yeah
I'm initially live that's cracked up oh
yeah so I don't know how to take those
just thought I promise oh I guess I
always dreamed of of being one oh that's
crazy yeah yeah and just
or I'd say my support coming right up
but yeah I remember when I was young I
was like oh I want to be an all black
one day yeah and you were you good like
from a young age
um well we're like you make like you'd I
guess you'd judge it by making rep teams
and stuff like that when you're younger
and me and Fonzie were we're in those a
lot together yeah I kind of
geez you remember some of the guys like
well Michael Leach one year oh yes lady
uh funny father was some a lot you could
look back at the old photos yeah like
his group funny and
um yeah like came through the gate Deco
yeah like so kind of we we all kind of
we were the same age we kind of came
through the the ranks down down here
together and
yeah Connor I guess yeah
I don't understand
yeah yeah I've always believed always
believed I could if you work hard enough
you can anyone can can do it so was it
always rugby was that the main sport for
you
yeah mum and dad were awesome I think
they were like if he's playing sport
he's not getting in the [__] yeah you
know like so they'll always like
Athletics or my mom's dad was a really
good swimmer so and she was kind of
pushed me and my brother and sister gone
into swimming oh yeah this is not a bad
idea living in NZ but
um that was too much hard to like
once I got to like 5 a.m starts when uh
so yeah like swimming volleyball
basketball
um like Athletics sure you just like
everything just like get into it like
if I'm dead like drawing us all around
towns like non-stop but yeah yeah I
think they all kind of help with with
whatever kind of way you want to go if
it is rugby I think like your basketball
skills are applicable to to playing
rugby and your Athletics certainly
doesn't hurt it so things like that and
but yeah it was definitely like mum and
dad always if they're if they're
training or you know playing sport then
they're not getting into [__] so I think
that was why so your pathway out of
school
um I remember making the New Zealand 19s
20s yeah they were pretty stack teams
too yeah it's pretty cool when you kind
of getting it because we're always at
the trolls for those together right yeah
yeah like and I had the pleasure of
having your comms outside me one game
and I thought oh mate this if I'm not
gonna make the team with karate yet
sorry on no chance I didn't make it but
oh yeah yeah like so he played a high
school
um and then schools you said oh they're
New Zealand seven ends camp at um palmy
so it was the kind of first kind of
taste of it yeah
and that's when I remember that I was
stacked with tins like they had like
Tran DK
um and I was just Stacks are like oh you
can go to 12. oh yeah okay yeah you're
not gonna argue with anything so it's
like and then just kind of ever since
then like 17s and then there was when I
went back to I must have gone back to
Shirley there after that and played in
the Midfield and then yeah schools
um 1920s pretty cool cool um awesome
teams to be a part of and
um yeah also the academy and stuff was
really good here like at the corner I
remember our first year in the academy
and it's like there's a couple of us
that were still going to school and then
a couple guys that left school and they
used to make a scan and train at um end
up the gym in town at like
I think was like five or six a.m before
before school before work and
like I don't know if they were actually
like looking at the 10-year shifting or
like I reckon they just kind of see if
you turn up yeah and you're like oh and
basically all the guys that would turn
up would kind of make it into the
academy and once you kind of got that
that kind of that training base I found
that when you went to went to first 15
rugby you're kind of a little bit ahead
of the guys that weren't kind of doing
that sort of training if that makes
sense so I felt like that was a real
kind of party like a real crucial kind
of time and
I guess my 40 careers as well I kind of
got a good wee bit ahead just through
kind of working a little bit harder so
that was pretty cool and when you made
the New Zealand teams was there
um if there any opportunities to move to
another
Province or was it always Canterbury for
you yeah man I was mad can't have gone
up like I was like like Andrew mutants
was one of my favorite players growing
up um DC you know I used to be a ball
boy like oh yeah yeah so we'd kind of
get there before any of them right so
bees used to play yeah like God Scott
Hamilton was paying for the bees in it
is it he was awesome and we would get it
early and we'd like get kick goals and
pretend like we were yeah you know
playing and stuff and then so you kind
of balled with both games and give some
hot chips between you know half time and
I don't know it's just I guess stuff
like that kind of yeah just kind of
I know reseeds that kind of that dream
that you have and what your spider
aspired to before yeah um so yeah it was
yeah it was quite funny looking back
it's cool you've gone from that like
that ball went pretty quickly like it
wasn't long out of school that you were
then and that Canterbury set up playing
in the NPC was it man yeah it went real
quick I remember I tried to do some
study events like oh you know it was
when you first kind of make it and
they'll and like you're getting all the
PDM say hey look your rugby career is
average only three years and you're like
oh no
see like I remember doing some study and
like um
man the the she wasn't really
um like didn't really
care about rugby she's like if you miss
any more classes on the value I can't
think so and it was like pretty much
straight out of school so I was like
crying I'm trying to yeah pretty much
so yeah it was it was pretty quick like
um yeah it was pretty much straight out
um
I think I think that first year
Crusaders I think Casey broke his arm so
it was like straight in there yeah it
was
yeah you're linen leaning on the halt
pretty quick yeah um but they were
looking back it was awesome like you're
playing against guys I think when you
first come in like I remember I remember
John Smith like I was raised over Iraq
thinking oh it's like at that time and
he sees me and he just goes bang head
first
splits me like Harry Potter like I said
well welcome to the Super Rugby economy
like yeah just I think you've played
each week you're like playing against
guys that you've just the year ago
you're watching on TV a lot how awesome
is he that's quite a quite like you get
Starstruck I think that that first kind
of season or two that yeah and I'm
guessing you're a star strike probably
the most in your own side you guys had a
oh you spoke about yeah idle being Dan
Carter and then next minute you're
outside I'm trying to tell them where
where the space is my it's um
yeah I remember that I mean we had a
really experienced Ford pacade when I
first came like Jacko
um franksy uh Brad Thorne I think was
still there yeah
um
oh mate yeah that was stag macaw yeah
yeah
you don't even want to call for the ball
out of the back oh yeah you guys take it
but yeah and then you like like you're
starting with a conversation and Danny
playing at DC and it's like
you don't want to sign anything because
how you're the best player in the world
I might could go a couple things that's
quite um yeah it was interesting
learning it was a real kind of it was
cool like cool couple years ago but you
kind of learn like a thing that was when
it slowly but old school kind of old
school Real Environment was kind of just
kind of phasing out yeah but it was the
old you know Pegasus cup of tea or or
cutting the boats or and your stripes
yeah and your stripes stay out the front
of the basketball yeah yeah thank you
you get three seats man no no no no no
so how did you get over that
um I guess that not fair but
um ability to give Dan Carter a message
or and feed and what you're actually
saying how long did it take you to feel
comfortable there oh I think a bit of
time once you once you've kind of been
in the saddle or wee bit and you feel
kind of comfortable enough to contribute
you know I think yeah it maybe took a
season or two like it took a bit but um
quite a real high like respect for
authority so if I see those guys as
like I wouldn't challenge like I
wouldn't challenge those those guys
especially when I was younger so
um so you're kind of just just happy to
fit in and and do your job and just not
kind of
um yeah it took a bit of good use into
it and they kind of helped they're
really good at helping you along as well
like he was a couple times I need you to
you know I need this from you and he was
really good like that too yeah oh mate
that's so cool and talk to me about your
sort of Canterbury because you're going
Canterbury
um Crusaders canopy Crusaders for about
winning titles
um probably winning the shield no doubt
without a few
um memories from those uh games what do
you remember yeah I always remember
Super Rugby was always like the um
it was like the high pressure kind of
season like it was always really intense
big physical games like and it was
always long Learners and travel and
stuff so it was it was a real it was
enjoyable it was still a grind it was
still really tough and then I always
remember going back to Canterbury was
almost like it would almost had to be
but it was always
oh how good like we're going to play
running rugby we're gonna we're gonna
attack wide offset piece all the time
we're gonna we're gonna have fun because
it kind of had to be to kind of get to
decompress from a from a super campaign
and I remember early on
um pins was did an unreal job like um
like coming into Canterbury especially
because he had a really young group and
like I just remember being fun like
really fun
um some of my you know Fondest Memories
of of um you know Canterbury campaigns
and some of the stuff used to do off the
field and a lot of the team building
stuff it was it was always really really
good
um and I think and I think it was also
like a lot of guys that missed out on a
b so yeah they were disappointed and
they needed something fun to come back
to and
um yeah and I think that probably
translated into a lot of their positive
performances you know so you know and
and also like your mates that you make
kind of playing those campaigns because
we're a core group of us at paidy like a
heck of a lot of games together that you
know we were kind of well the further on
we got we'd
um would not make
all blacks so we'd all go back to
um Canterbury and so we're just playing
a lot a lot of like a whole year
together and those kind of friendships
and connections were really cool and I
think they were you know they kind of
helped us you know play well too and you
mentioned that all blacks are missing
out on the All Blacks when did you start
feeling like you were a chance to be in
become an all black were you
disappointed early on with some of the
missed selections so I think what was it
like four or five years before you
became an all black or did you feel like
you weren't really up until basically
you were you were named
I remember having a conversation with
Honda like way back in the day and I
remember him saying like
do you think you ever feel ready like to
go into the ABS I don't I don't know if
you like I don't know if you would like
I wouldn't like you never felt ready no
you never feel like yeah I remember when
I got caught up and it might have been
13 when yeah when I had to go over for
their first game and like he I think it
might have been him who said it to me so
I did but would you ever feel ready I
was like yeah it's a it's a good point
maybe you wouldn't like
so yeah he must be already now
my bolty record here first
yeah so
um yeah I was never disappointed you
always hope you know you always you
always trying and that's that's the
ultimate goal isn't it yeah so but no I
wouldn't so to point in you you've got
to look at you know missing out as an
opportunity for something else yeah so
when you did finally get name what was
it like
my first game was 13 and it was I think
snake in what I had to go home during
the week I think
um I think it might have been maybe his
first child maybe I think yeah it might
have been so anyway you're there in
Sydney and um
make Shandy calls and it was like a
Monday or Tuesday it's like pack your
bags so we're not in the squat no I
wasn't in the squad oh wow so out of
nowhere mate yeah I don't know I can't
remember I was I was like you jacket
he's like that because I know he's a
family friend so oh yeah yeah
good one but
um mate yes yeah okay like I know I
can't make it yet so busy
so straight on the bar mum and dad
[Music]
um
tickets and I had a couple of mates like
but um from from surely like we've got
an awesome group of mates yeah really
good group of ads that are still really
tight and I had a couple of my best
mates they were kind of on are we all
living in the UK yeah and they always
said oh we believe we reckon you're
going to be an OB one day and we won't
miss your first one so I called it buff
and that one of them was in Wales and I
think two of them were in one was in
Wales one was in Adelaide and another
one might have been in London so I rang
them I'd let them know I say boys I'm
gonna gonna Sydney yeah to that tonight
like just letting you know like that
yeah and mate they all they were all
there yeah they all flew back and
they're all there so
um yeah Sydney there for the week just
man blue just like [__] scared like
um yeah and there was um we're starting
and I came off the bench yeah came off
the bench and played about I think 30 35
minutes I think off the beach oh awesome
yeah so cool like and probably the
coolest thing was like catch up with Dad
after the game giving him a hug seeing
how emotional he was and and also like
all the ticks you kind of get that week
probably the the biggest realization is
the kind of the satisfaction
that everyone else has on your success
because a lot like you don't do it on
your own yeah everyone everyone who's
helped you along the way has contributed
to that moment yeah so that's probably
the coolest thing like seeing the
happiness that you know your success can
bring other people yeah because that
helped you so that's cool it is cool and
you obviously went pretty well because
then you went to the India tour
yeah it went played that game came back
played for Canterbury for the rest of
the season and that was good fun and
then
yeah we played Wellington in the final
and then four o'clock the next morning
after the final we were at the airport
flying out on India tour so sure
hell of a celebration
stumbling onto the bike
all right yeah it was it was cool it was
yeah like awesome just to get like
touring for the ABS yeah in the UK like
or unreal such a cool rugby experience
like looking back now yeah yeah when
you're when you're there you don't
really you probably died towards the
India I'm mindful to like really realize
how good it is but yeah now looking back
like it's such a such a cool time like
yeah touring the UK oh unreal and your
first try is probably must be one of the
most memorable experiences of your
career really like that try to beat
Island and what was it 83 or four
minutes however come back scoring the
match one of that crew and then has to
kick a memory that must um sit right up
there for you far out it's probably I
can't be mad at cozy for being such a
grub in every game
well he must have punched me and
probably two or three rocks at least but
I can't be mad at him because he doesn't
you know he put that on a plate of me
um
that was fine it was cool it was cool
just to kind of feel like you've
contributed something to to the team
yeah like
um but man I didn't do anything like
yeah I called her five meters out and
fell over the line like didn't and I was
guest stairs because that that last
phase was just so quick yeah I'm only
getting up from Iraq and that girl just
yelling at me God's get like he's
screaming at me to get to the wing yeah
so I pulled the stream at me to pull
with so go go to the wing where you
don't have to do anything yeah I mean
cozy just here you go sir but we always
confident that you guys were gonna win
that game or did yeah because obviously
you've been in the team for that long
but
um it was one of those moments where
it's like wow that is
it is good my I think well there was a
pretty special group that that kind of
2013 season I think kind of just being a
new guy going in like I remember I
remember the game I remember when 16 was
taking that kick oh yeah
I remember like if he had a if he had a
kicked out there was no way we could
have come out like looking back but I
probably wasn't really conscious of the
scoreboard you're kind of just focus and
like just really like really ruthlessly
on your task yeah but um I remember
thinking I was like even if this goes
over we're still going to win but that's
literally the feeling that you had like
yeah and that was probably for quite a
sustained period for the ABS but I just
remember having that that Connor
um
yeah I think he's maybe that's the guys
around you yeah and maybe the the
success that the team's kind of had over
a period but um I just remember really
clearly thinking that which was an
hindsight very wrong
so so you're confident krudz is going to
kick that one from the sideline my yeah
yeah he's he's kicked enough against us
Chief said you know he's
um but we actually we played um
we played santori in the semi-final yeah
and he was the 10 and they had a mall
try that got disallowed in the final
minute of the game and he was gonna need
a kick from the exact same spot
to win it for them and I was just like
damn it there's been not be a try
because he'll probably ice it I've seen
this before yeah yeah Deja Vu a very
different feeling what about your goal
kicking did you like you were gulking
back at school would you have wanted
that kick from the sideline or
are easy to say yes now he's at a yeah
mate I don't know
um mate look let's really like
that's probably like what I'd say to
young young players I just don't let
that kind of thing don't give that kind
of thing up because I remember when I
first came to Canterbury like I'd have
been like seventh Choice Kaka or
something we were absolutely stacked
Stevie Britt Slade
Hamish guard
um like Tales might even be in there
there was just heaps and heaps of
goalkeepers and they're like oh we'll
cry to you sex string so I was like I'll
put the tea away Frick yeah for the
season never really like kept it up yeah
but it was something I really enjoyed
like the kind of challenge of
goalkeeping yeah yeah so in hindsight I
should have should have kept up but
whether I would have wanted to take one
against Ireland time up
or third game yeah I think it was like
fifth game
maybe if I was lucky yeah no probably
probably not probably not so after a try
like that do you start feeling more
comfortable in the environment or like
do you did you feel like you belonged
there yeah but probably more so just
because of the the mates that I had like
the connections I had within like
amongst the team by then like you just
have time and you have time to get to
know people and and you know like I
remember that tours like spend a lot of
time with like um bender and cozy and
tire with her and just got you know
you've got your group of mates that you
then you feel more comfortable kind of
and amongst it so and then you obviously
time on the field that's a massive part
of you know feeling like you're part of
a team and
um so yeah so yeah the more time I spent
in the group they're kind of more
comfortable but I don't think you ever
really feel comfortable in an ABS
environment I think there's always that
it's a bit of age or that bit of the
pressure that they like to have
in the environment so you know when you
get to a game you're used to it so yeah
and were you like that sort of every all
black announcement like sitting on the
edge uh not sure if you're in or out
obviously you you missed a few the 2015
World Cup squad
um how hard was that one for you to take
yeah I don't think you ever you'd never
take it for granted like me personally I
was in and out enough times to know that
you just don't like and yeah 2015 was an
example of that
um that was it was a tough it was tough
to take it was um
yeah I was got it like um
but then in hindsight I probably didn't
deserve it like I wasn't I wasn't better
than Conrad my sunny and Muller was
playing really well so I was like
you know the only person you'd be
frustrated is yourself because you're
not playing good enough and you have
complete control over that so
um but obviously yeah I wanted to be
there because all my mates were there
and it's a little cup and how good but
yeah it was it was in hindsight it was
probably like one of the best things
that happened like I missed out on that
but
um
I reacted to it really well which I was
you know proud of I came back here for
Canterbury and really invested into that
group and had one of my most enjoyable
and best seasons and
um you know connected really well and
um and then the next year and then I was
ready to take the opportunity in 2016
and and really talk it because I was
really hungry for it because I missed
out so
um yeah frustrating but in hindsight you
know
you learn from setbacks and I was glad I
took that learning it's tougher because
like you mentioned when you got named
how happy you are that everyone's you
know enjoying your success and how how
much joy that brings in and then on the
flip side when you miss out how much
pain it sort of gives them because they
think you're in so much pain but really
it's you're thinking that they're in
pain you know it's that weird sort of
feeling eh bro 100
yeah because you you kind of forget that
everyone's on the rod with yeah yeah
like your family and
yeah you can't you do forget that
because you do kind of have to be a wee
bit selfish to you know in your own
world and you're doing everything you
need to do to prepare and play and it
does get away but like um you kind of
have to be a little bit I think so
um yeah you do you forget that
everyone's on the on the ride with you
so yeah yeah it's it's a yeah it's funny
you mentioned that yeah you know you're
spot on and then obviously the following
year you're back in there
um starting a bit more you become sort
of First Choice midfielder yeah it was
it was also I really like it was a real
strong goal like man 16 17 well 16 was
just to kind of establish myself as a as
a starting all black and
hold it down for for a whole season and
um
and obviously the Lions was a pretty big
cat but yeah it was just yeah 16 was
was good from the learning from the year
before so it was it was a great season
we really enjoyed it
um enjoyed the challenge of like um
because it is such a challenge in that
environment and International Rugby so
um that was it was a really memorable
Year from
from like just knuckling down and
working really hard and and getting some
reward on the back of that because it
wasn't sort of just miss selection that
you had to deal with you had a so many
injuries throughout your career
particularly concussions a few others as
well but it was definitely something
throughout your career you you had a
tough time with yeah I think they just
part of the probably the most
frustrating part of the game like
introduce a lot
and like I can get
like frustrated but I'm still probably
like really
like just grateful for like the crit
like I've played for I don't even know
how many years now like it must be yeah
getting down there so like in the at the
in the time at the moment like in that
moment of being injured that's like
frustrating yeah it's like can't see the
end can't yeah but then you come out the
other side and you're oh it wasn't that
bad yeah you know so it's quite a it's a
funny one but yeah like like I'm pretty
much an expert on concussions anyone
that can they just had me out they're
like hey man I was like I might go to
Japan for four years you'll be right
so but yeah it's um us part of the game
yeah you see the voice here going
through it like you've always been hit
pretty hard this season and
um
yeah like like any we sit back you just
gotta deal with it and as best you can
and use it as a a challenge I guess and
I guess that's what I did every time and
I was pretty lucky I've always had good
like especially around here really good
care and especially like you say around
the concussions Doc's great here and
really good physios around that kind of
thing so
um I think this is part of the game yeah
so what did a concussion look like like
obviously you had
I think was it like six and just over a
year like it was a pretty
um decent tally like what did it look
like at its worst for you oh the thing
is the worst part about it was the noise
like what everyone says about it and
stuff like you read about it in the
media that's the worst part of it oh
yeah yeah so like I guess because I had
a couple like quite close together
um like it was
um
I guess it became easier to get kincas
if that makes sense yeah so
um but then like I said the most
frustrating thing was was the media and
stuff but I found with my my ones person
I think everyone's different but with my
ones I would recover really quickly okay
yeah so like I did all sorts of stuff
seeing like a neurologist here in
Christchurch and
um having cognitive brain function tests
done and like I was my my Baseline shows
I don't know whether it's just trying to
make me feel good but she's like
you're a genius she is
I reckon she was just [__] me so I
could go back to she's like a massive
Crusaders
it was awesome like I was really well
looked after and that's that's half of
it yeah the kind of piece of mind and
how you actually
feel about it
um but now I mean I recovered quick like
like genuinely and then um
I think it was mostly like a week or two
at a time I just had to take away smoko
and like Let It settle down and then I
was good to go again so when you've done
anything differently because you were
getting them you know like you said they
were becoming easier for you to get can
cast would you have done anything
differently in hindsight looking back or
not really no I feel good you ready to
go yeah it felt good yeah like um no I
probably wouldn't because I feel like
the processes that they haven't placed
around that kind of thing are yeah are
really good so if you follow those and
they're so mindful of it now like
um no if you just do the right things
and you do if you do right by you yeah
then you can't really that's out there
you go yeah that's it exactly
yeah yeah and you mentioned the media I
guess like I remember the media like
they're basically starting a campaign
for you to retire after at the I don't
know the fifth or sixth one like did you
feel any pressure to retire did that
ever come across your thought process
that maybe it was time to give the game
up no
no not really like um
no it wasn't like because I probably
would have known if they were really bad
yeah but because they weren't they were
like little just just just like little
dings I guess if that's uh if that's the
way you describe the concussion
but the thing was I was recovering well
I didn't feel like I was like I was
never having headaches I was I was
actually like if I was like you get one
and you have like a feeling of not
feeling quite right and then it would
take a few a couple of days and then
you'd start to come right and feel fine
again so it was I think you'd have to be
held out of the next week just because
it's you know you're not all right so
um
yeah so I never really felt like like
retirement was a real thing and then and
then like like honestly four years in
Japan like nothing like was it luck or
is it is a game just less physical there
I don't know yeah
um but yeah so it's it's quite funny how
will most of your concussions what were
they caused from or all sorts of
different things yeah like sometimes
it's just getting a neat like a knee at
the bottom of a rock or
trying to trying to bite Jack goodhue's
head
um you know you're coming off second
best of that
um just really nothing yeah like really
innocuous like and just different
nothing sometimes it's making a tackle
and yeah sometimes it's just carrying
the ball like yeah yeah it's interesting
it is yeah is it has it still been much
around it how's the season like Super
Rugby been for that kind of thing pretty
I feel like it's been less this year
than yeah ever really yeah it's
everything else yeah that's always
something yeah oh mate you have a year
yeah yeah
oh I know so then um we'll go back to
your all black career and the 2019 World
Cup that year
um that was obviously a massive year for
you and
um the All Blacks so what do you
remember about that yeah and that
selection yeah it was it was awesome to
experience the World Cup yeah it's just
it was different eh it was World Cup you
don't realize how different World Cup
rugby is there's kind of tournament
format
but um
oh it was
oh and so look it was frustrating we
didn't win so it was obviously that that
see our taste in your mouth and um but
like I just remember it was
oh we prepared really well and the
Cooper's in a pretty good place and just
um some just really good learnings
around that that week I remember the All
Blacks always
I remember Gilbert quite often will talk
about like having a really Elite
Performance one week and then there was
always a challenge to back it up again
like stay at that level or even go again
it was quite often kind of you'd often
find it in a bleed as I first test that
Connor first game against Aussie there
um
I guess the unknown yeah that corner
fear or uneasiness would
um
would mean you'd get that really bone
deep preparation you'd just go over
everything and then you'd get a really
good performance and I don't know
whether
I don't know whether the second one was
uh I don't think it's complacency but
there's just not that same it's not the
same yeah so then it would quite often
the the two performances would
you know be a little bit different so
that there was always a kind of thing so
back-to-back performances how do you
kind of back it up and
he I don't know like I guess that was
maybe a learning in that I'm not
learning but we didn't quite get it
right in that that semi-final so that
was it was um
no I just it just hurts I guess and
you feel for the group and everyone and
yeah it's just um but like you say to go
to World Cup was really cool really cool
that was in Japan yeah it was awesome
kind of getting a taste of that before
kind of going to live there yeah and it
was just a real a real shame about
covert because on the back of that on
the back of the Cup rugby was her sin in
Japan like they were really about it yes
so they they'll get behind stuff like
that yeah they're really oh awesome
supporters so
um mate yeah it was a real shame that
covert really kind of
yeah yeah and what about your um
selection in the Samuel you missed
selection for that semi how hard was
that for you to take did you feel like
you you want you you obviously wanted to
be out there do you feel like you
deserve to be out there you would have
made a difference or hard to say I'd say
in hindsight eh anything you can say
stuff like that but no it was it was
just gutting yeah getting to know I have
the opportunity but um but that's just
the way it goes like I kind of learned
like like I've had so many awesome
moments like
you can get hung up on the ones you
don't get or you can just be grateful
for the ones that you do yes
um and man I've had been so especially
with this team
in the ABS with Canada like I've just
been so lucky to have
that many awesome kind of memories and
moments and and mates that um yeah I got
more to be grateful for than than to be
disappointed about so
um yeah but I was like I was lucky like
I'd bend over there as well and we were
in the same boat and he'd put he'd be my
best mate in the ABS and we spent a lot
of time together and it was cool Connor
you know we could be filthy about it but
then hey look mate we've got to train we
got to prepare the ball as well today
and focus on that and he and it was
really good for me with that too so it
was um yeah and you got your send off in
the third and fourth against Warehouse
yeah yeah it was it was a weird one hey
it's a really strange week there boy oh
but but like how do you get up for that
but then you do you do you're like man
why not like how good like we're playing
in the game another game at the World
Cup and
um you kind of I remember that week I'm
all Drew from the guys I was playing
with like I was playing with Carl was he
playing with Bender you know playing
with Nike and all these guys Sonny you
know all these guys you've played
readout like all these guys who've just
played so much code word throughout your
Korean this is the last time you're
gonna put on the Jersey so draw a motion
and
use that emotion to fuel your intent
kind of through that so that was that
was It was a
it was a weird one but it was a moment
that you still got to take in in my dad
mum and dad there and Terry was there
too so yeah yeah good yeah and you
mentioned all the moments that you're
grateful for like um some of the
memories in the Crusaders all this what
are what a few that really stand out
like celebrating championships are
awesome yeah 17 was really cool a few of
those very lucky like yeah you 17 as an
Africa right yeah man of the match too
yeah yeah yeah
what a time you don't miss anything
memory oh man that was cool like that
was such a special
or just win that final who to win I just
can remember the feeling yeah oh
my the Elation they're just a genuine
just the feeling was just unbelievable
like because it was like for a lot of us
it was like
2009 lost the CME 2010 lost assembly
2011 lost the final was that the waratah
as well 2000 levels the Reds right 2012
lost to semi 2013.
maybe lost to see me
2014 lost the final oh yeah 2015 missed
playoffs
2016 lost a quarter so it was like you'd
had just like yeah oh man don't really
remember like people don't really
remember the Crusaders going through
that patch yeah well then like I guess
that's the standard that it is yeah like
you win finals or you it's a failure
whereas DSA other teams might be
satisfied with making the playoffs or
whereas I remember us I just remember it
was just the boys are filthy like you
lose a quarterfinal the boys are just
just nothing yeah so I guess to you have
that kind of sustain so close so so
close and never had it and then it was
awesome because there's a group of us in
that team that had been there for all of
that yeah and you're kind of like but
the 2008 they won so the year after like
oh we got here and we haven't won
anything
so I just remember that the relief but
also just how hard it was yeah like how
hard that Journey had been to finally
win one and also like to do it in Esa
and edit packed out Alice Park you know
on the road no team had ever done it so
that was that was that was right up
there man that was a really cool it was
a really really cool cool moment
um and then like Milestone games like I
remember my 150th I'm a raid that are
awesome awesome job at making it special
for me and so I like to to kind of reach
that was a really cool cool moment and
and that was mainly because that
performance was a really good
performance that weekend
um yeah and then and then just like all
the all the normal stuff as well like
going on tour with the lads and just
just
just like um
probably the mates probably your friends
the connections the genuine friendships
that you make near the corner they're
the moments of memories that you that
you remember the best I reckon hey
hundred percent everyone says it but it
is it is so true yeah I think everyone
remembers yeah connections that makes
the most you know like you kind of
remember the game yeah yeah and like you
remember like guys are good players and
stuff but you remember if they're a good
bugger yeah yeah it's just um
yeah I think that's the cool thing about
the game mate yeah it gives you those
opportunities to make those mates and
create those kind of memories and stuff
so then why did you um decide to go to
Japan like when you decided that before
the World Cup right yeah just timing was
right money was good yeah pretty much
pretty much that that was awesome how
that came about actually like I was kind
of I was tossing up between France and
it wasn't a lot in Japan and I remember
we I think we played at blitters over
there it might have been 18. oh yeah and
um me and Ben were gonna go catch up
with Stokes who's like the he was the he
was the Ford's coach been playing and
gone and coached and I had a promo or
something so Ben to win and caught up
with him and he's like oh he said
concert's actually looking for something
over here in bang next day contract
through really yes soaks mate shout out
Orlando's mate now
um yeah he and I was like my agent's
like can you fly back to Japan after
um India tour because it was on the way
to India toy played the better and I was
like I've been here for two weeks like
yeah should we've been to the commission
or he's like no no no don't be silly so
um yeah and then this came about and um
oh great opportunity I just I just felt
like it was the time like I've been here
for maybe 11 or 12 years by then so
um and we got we had awesome guys coming
through like like they do you always do
that well here the kind of succession
plan for guys that are kind of
transitioning um out of the Crusaders
and having guys just ready to step in so
um and also from the All Blacks as well
like it was just just time for me to go
it felt right felt like I'd done
everything I could here and given it as
good a crackers
I could have and um didn't really feel
like I was running away from anything
yeah whereas if I remember I feel like
if I had gone in the past I felt like I
was kind of maybe running from a
challenge or just
um you know that kind of thing so yeah
yeah kind of just felt right that was
the right timing so is that sort of why
you stayed here as long as you did
especially in the Crusaders like I
remember a period when they signed guys
like Sunny Bill and
um you know obviously you earned that
starting spot and then he comes in and
you're pushed back down and then how
does that make you feel to make you feel
like you want to go to another franchise
um you were pretty much in all black so
exactly
yeah like um yeah that's a challenge man
like like I'm pretty like love Crusaders
like yes I grew up you know I always
wanted to be one
but like I think
I remember when Sonny came
it was just a challenge like you just
yeah you can't control what you can
control so knuckle down and do
everything you can to try and get it
back and I kind of playing a ton of
clubs for today yeah yeah
um but that was just the way it went
like that's if you're not good he's
better than me so if I was better than I
would have been playing it's just the
reality yeah so that's you sometimes you
just got to take it on the chin if
you're not if you're not good enough so
I guess that was a bit of that and then
2015 we're gonna miss out on the World
Cup that was probably the main one where
you're getting like decent offers from
overseas and yeah France and that's the
kind of one that you're like oh
geez what I do here but then that was
the one like
like I hadn't been a consistent all
black I hadn't like really tested how
hard I can push myself and hadn't had
like the
the real challenge you know and I wanted
that and I felt like if I had gone
overseas I'd have been running away from
The Challenge so that was probably why I
didn't didn't really go that's a cool
mindset and I feel like it's pretty
unique these days once when someone gets
you know when if Sonny Bill came in and
ahead of someone I feel like a lot of
guys would sort of dropped their lap and
want to move to another franchise and
sort of prove them right that they're
you know want to go against them you
know so
um being able to hang in there and
eventually become 152 game Legend
um shows shows a lot about you I'll
appreciate that man yeah well like it's
like you you define whether whatever
situation whatever decision you make
becomes a good one yeah dang it like
like you decide that and then you go
about making it a good decision so
no that's that's Connie to say you do
have those thoughts are you like huh
yeah you know what I mean then you kind
of take the time to to actually like
think about it like ah no that's just a
that's a cop-out like you know like yeah
but
cheers man right how good and obviously
you're back now
um what is good could reunite you
reignite your all black Crusader career
who knows what he's feeling good looking
sharp at training oh yeah one thing that
a lot of guys like they come on the
podcast and then they put it out there
and things seem to happen for them so
right like that's that's why I'm here
that's what I'm saying where do you want
to go mate Tommy's Book Sales through
the roof after her Cody's Eclipse mate
this is where it happens this is where
the magic happens right some of these
books you can't make enough at the
moment sad banana is going oh through
the roof but and then I guess after
footy like um I know you're what 34
um have you got have you got honor
you're not retiring yet but have you got
much of a idea of what you want to do
Post footing no I really don't yeah I
don't and it's almost the challenge has
been okay with that yeah I think like I
don't think many guys do like I listen
to your party with tell me I thought
that was awesome like he's been such a
good teammate oh man he's he's a gym
yeah like and listen to that even listen
to things like that like oh that's
actually really really helpful I imagine
it would have been helpful for a lot of
guys yeah in the similar position to
myself
um but I I don't like it I'm very
fortunate I've had a good long career
and I've I've been really smart with
what I've earned and saved really well
and invested well so I'm have the luxury
of having time when I do decide to hang
them up I don't know whether I'm just
kicking the can down the road a little
bit further at the moment
um but no I'm not too sure and and I
think I'm okay with that yeah yeah so
but I guess there's so many things about
rugby that I love like that would
potentially
might well I'd actually ask you the
question like going from a player to a
coach like
what kind of itches does that scratch
from gun from being a rugby player to
now coaching like right the reverse
podcast
it takes a lot of the boxes you're
getting all the same things
um you had as a as a player except your
body's feeling over here more meetings
the conditioning chain is optional
obviously you're spending a hell of a
lot more time on the computer okay so if
you enjoy that like I reckon I'd
recommend it and you're obviously
someone who's
um very smart rugby brain so I feel like
if you wanted to go into coaching
um what's left of it yeah
do you suffer from it like you've got no
symptoms no nothing at all nothing like
handy like yeah you're like you've had
another test and it's still Einstein
oh man oh anyway we'll get into some of
these questions
um I hate I can't even imagine all right
who's coming out of the Woodworks mate
is um this first one this one's just
popped in from Brad Weber so I do want
to read this because it is a it is a
good one it's about a time where you
um
2019 World Cup you stayed at the same
um hotel as Floyd Mayweather and they
organized after come in and speak where
you had to interview them
um and you were so nervous Palms were
sweating jittery
um sweating and ended up being civil who
rocked in with his shirt off so what do
you remember about that oh does he not
okay so so caught often like ABS would
have a club rooms on a Tuesday night or
even with the club Jersey yeah it would
be like like you know like a rugby club
yeah I think it was a Wayne Smith
initiative awesome awesome way to
decompress on a Tuesday
um but I'd often interview guys that
would come in so I remember the Mertz
once he was Unreal he was one of the
best we've had like just he's got chat
he's funny like he doesn't take it
serious good yeah
um who else we head in where do I will
eat once in a while there's pretty
pretty intense right yeah kiwi hero
who did Fitzy over in London oh yeah
he's different I was there he's old
school man old school Connor
yeah
interesting yeah I need to take notes
but it makes what a lad guess yeah it's
right up yeah mate get him on he would
he'd be one of them
um and we so we had a few like you kind
of go somewhere and I think they had
like adesanya and I think Richard about
last year but we were in Tokyo um saying
it like this ritzy hotel and we would
notice all these bodyguards around in
May with it was there yeah
and kind of what happened was like so
myself only three of us
the security guard Bender myself
and someone else might have been Sammy
Kane or might have been Gilbert I'm not
sure but a few of us were in on it well
okay we're gonna we're gonna tell the
boys that we're getting Mayweather to
come in and so so
I don't know but but like
so we gather around like I'm acting
nervous life yeah what do you want me to
ask him well geez you're a good actor
but like I was going around like and
then I started to convince myself what
if he does walk yeah then I am so maybe
so I was kind of acting but maybe I'd
like Double Bluff myself that he might
have been coming in so I'm actually like
you pranked yourself
so I'm actually Angela surely he's not
she always does money made with it we
can't afford him but so yeah so and
everyone's like Connor
like start up some Rocky music and see
who comes in an interesting game like it
was it was a good laughing got a few of
them like obviously got Webbie but um I
must have sold it well maybe about what
an actor life after 40 days
did you meet him now or no you just saw
him from afar no he was just kind of he
said his bodyguards are massive oh yeah
big dudes yeah and he was just all blend
up like his posse was like man like he
had like 40. 40 people just follow him
around it was it was quite strange Next
Level he's big and
um in Japan like he's a pretty yeah well
he's pretty yeah
well I think he did like an exhibition
fight and it was just like yeah hacked
out yeah Japanese love stuff like that
though yeah he's yeah okay good start
okay next one uh we I set one around did
we not want to ask anything about the
fantasy
okay next one worst Miss tackle of your
career oh it might be Tom's in that end
first times yes
yeah he put me on the toilet oh stuck in
the mud and then he did this
oh you'll be able to find the footage oh
yeah man he just stunned me Clan he was
probably one of the hardest guys to
tackle was he him and gets I remember
playing oh man my first game I was like
he's probably like
been like a smaller Midfield I used to
look up to guys like ham I dress school
yeah
um
even to arms like but I remember I was
like first game against get out I was
like I'm gonna get him to get him behind
the game line here get him like bang hit
spin he's 20 meters down what just
happened like yeah because there's only
small a mate he is but he was he was
such a good player yeah he was Unreal so
I remember that and I also remember yeah
time's just far out I think he hit spin
offload like behind the back oh the
boy's almost still covered for me but it
was just that was pretty bad mess
you never you never remember the ones
you make you only ever remember the ones
you missed well that's good you've only
got two so that's pretty good man I've
got 500 of my head just going through
every day plenty more okay
um best midfielder you played with and
why oh great question
hey so many good hard to pick just one
oh man
so many good
uh I love playing with Jack yeah I love
playing with him smart smart just
indecisive
I might I was good to play with yeah it
was Just Energy it wasn't always up
played one game was snaky that was
pretty cool because I always like
thought
like I always try to model my game
around him because he was just just so
so smart so so clinical just just so
good um
oh man and I love playing with Timmy
just because I got like a real
like a lot of history with him in a real
soft spot for for him as a mate so yeah
hard to make what a four yeah could you
turn Bateman conrades yeah I hate you
could go I could say any of that I was a
play with and I could just talk so
highly of any of them so yeah that's
cool okay next one will the bed come
back huh isn't enough here though to
make the beer come back no no chance I'm
looking old enough as it is check out
the wrinkles on this forehead I'm trying
to look younger now not older no okay
what about that the other one's the bowl
cut
oh it's everything's gonna make you come
back no maybe oh when did you have the
bowl cut I don't remember having a bowl
okay was it who's it who's even said
that was that Super Rugby no that was
like high school filthy yeah yeah mum
told me it was cool oh yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it was like you know the undercut yeah
oh yeah the part oh man Backstreet Boys
must have had it that's maybe why but
you are right everything does sort of
swing around like the Mallet look at the
moment you only really need one big name
to bring back the bowl cat Never Say
Never And I reckon you're the guy
never say never
okay Beard's gone but bull cat's back
okay what was your nickname in
go oh it must be Game of Thrones is it
oh Dot
is it who is is that Bender or nag or
who was I
was drawer drawer draw a moment look
alike no like well we all kind of so
okay
not a Game of Thrones man but you know
get on it oh great show am I not too
late no no too late we um we had a crew
like uh ab's like um
fire ant would start
I could start off as a big group but we
just started watching Game of Thrones
oh yeah start off as a big group but it
kind of ended up being myself Bender
Nagi Joe Locke the media manager I think
it was us but at the start it was like
Nate Harris yeah Nate Harrison
portal
Aaron had the worst Aaron was Joffrey
Bender was need stock and I was drawing
he's just kind of like the just a
battler yeah yeah needs that need was
like the good guy who just got his head
cut off right oh I won't spoil it for
you sorry anyone else that says and
watched it yet but it was it was good it
was quite cool like things like that
yeah you just kind of literally watched
the whole like I don't know how many
seasons seven or something correct as a
group like right through like kind of
Tours and over a couple Seasons yeah
love it okay next one
are you coming back to New Brighton for
a run with Phil Burley this season is
Phil Burley back in town player I think
he just got back like a couple days ago
oh yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna get down and
try and play next week oh yeah yeah
man the crowd will turn out for that one
the return
he's gonna be a crowd down there not
sure what kind of crowd um yeah make
sure you lock your car over right
now I've always wanted to go back and
play yeah I've just always had a
contract and the risk of getting injured
playing Club rugby they'll tear contract
up yeah back overseas and now I've got
the um freedom to be able to
um unfortunately my way with the well
not unfortunately but me and the girls
are going to Hamner this weekend so oh
yeah um I'll get down next week I think
they've got a couple of round robin
games left so it'd be great to get down
you're gonna just be in time for finals
are they in the finals race now I think
the gun I think it's a pretty tight yeah
another one a lot in your career yeah
never never take it off mate how good
would that be gold kicking
can you take me for some practice right
for this one coming in I'll lock your
Knicks now next Tuesday so make sure you
reckon we get fonts to light them up
yeah definitely oh what a background
that would be okay next one
um do you enjoy contact training
oh
um this is from your character who
signed you mate
Orlando oh yeah good
um yeah love it no the boys rents me
over there So like um
[__] a new man oh sorry in Japan they
would have um
like G1 two three and four and Four's
like hessing um and so they got G4 and I
was like
hey games on Saturday boys like no so
like quite often I just wouldn't like
I'd just like that tackle yeah yeah mate
well just because it's what you used to
hear yeah you guys are smart even you
say I was getting smoked
you see listening I got like Bruce ribs
he got me good
um
so like yes I was quite surprised
yesterday level but no no
um yeah it's a lot different in Japan
yeah like we like I said first started
double Tuesday double Thursday full
contact it's just like how are you gonna
guys Peak on Saturday if you yeah so I
was trying to
I was trying to show them Saturday is
the most important thing but I was also
like
mate I'm just gonna do what's best for
me yeah I'm going to be able to hit on
Saturday I don't have to smoke anyone
and or myself on Tuesday Thursday so
yeah
a little bit selfish but that's probably
why you had no injuries or concussions
while you're over there for four years
because obviously a lot of it's training
yeah a lot of the time is training over
there so yeah it's they train that
decision yeah thanks mate thanks thanks
out of the bus that's good okay what
goes through your head in a close game
with a few minutes left oh love to go
inside this mine oh that's a good
question
[Music]
um
literally
I can't believe in Japan but like some
of the biggest stuff is the mental stuff
over there like um and that was probably
one of the things that helped us
be successful was just embracing the
mental performance side of the game and
really running with it
um shout out to John Quinn
um he gave me a coffee or two could we
could we could we cash you over there um
but no um I mean just just trying to
stay focused trying to really stay
focused at whatever I need to do
in that moment and
I guess as well as as if you I guess if
you're a leader then um
then deciding making decisions on what's
best for the team
um
so yeah I'll just say being been
ruthlessly focused on what I need to do
and and as well as connecting with the
people you need to to make decisions on
what the team needs in in those moments
oh like that gee that's good okay what's
the best end of season party you've had
oh man
end of season dues mate you would have
had so many in your 20-year career oh
man maybe
friend I remember like I remember one
year it was like maybe like a like a
fourth or fifth
Canterbury so Canterbury Championship so
nasimanu made us go for four or five
days compulsory compulsory team so no
one could tap out and if they tap out
you'd have to go in and get them oh it
was he was a really he's a great team
man he was awesome so maybe one of those
or otherwise it would be like um dress
upset at Carter's oh yeah dizzy had like
one of the best dress-up
um costume setups that you could get so
yeah I remember my brother's saying that
yes they always have good not good
dress-ups here right yeah let's that's
part of that um half of us now got
enough from those um Pizza Pasta dinners
from a few years ago yeah true to pull
out but um yeah like the Dizzy always
put on a good though and there's is a
good kind of social committee leader
yeah so have you got a good dress-up kit
now
I think 2006 at 18 19 we started going
for pizza party remember seeing them you
guys used to go to some things yeah oh
it got way out of hand that was yeah it
was another level it got really
expensive
you go higher Jack's very costume from
older that spot down in cashmere can't
see you back 150 bucks
never lost the game never lost the home
game like that on a dresser so that must
be the dress up surely right surely keep
the tradition
okay two two more yeah yeah any old
press cap stories
oh Prius capsules oh probably the only
thing oh
probably just thought how bad the
Mulberry referees are
all right we got in the tamaru river oh
we got absolutely
all right we got shafted a couple years
oh you don't forget eh better or better
yeah
high school rugby yeah this is such a
cool such a cool thing yeah like awesome
um
yeah I just just remember
I just kind of school with your mates
and then playing on the weekend this is
awesome
um
I think it's like high school rugby and
like Club rugby are like the real
essence of what rugby really is you know
that's that real humble kind of
I think the the yeah I won't say the
higher up you go you kind of lose it but
I just remembered I just reckon Club
rugby and um everyone's doing it for
nothing yeah exactly 100 that's exactly
that's exactly it but um
memories
besides losing to you boys like the
hackers or Kuwait that's probably a good
memory like did you ever lead it yeah
surely mate we always had a we always
had some brothers yeah
um yeah those those are probably there's
some cool memories here yeah okay last
one best piece of advice you have for a
woodland listener
this is what I was most excited about
getting on the podcast quite a bit of
advice yeah you're a wizard with advice
I don't know
um
man
just I'd say like I was kind of speaking
about it before but just like bo be okay
with
um I feel just being yourself be okay
with like however you feel about certain
things and and stuff like that I don't
know if that's really clear but like
um
man oh you know like I'm speaking
probably because where I'm at in my life
right now yeah I'd say like in terms of
my Rugby career just
man if you want something and you work
hard you're gonna like it'll happen like
literally working hard being smart
having a plan like you will get to where
you need to go to if if you work hard
right don't make excuses just get on
with it and if you want something enough
and you work hard enough
it always takes care of itself 100 when
did you make your plan like
um man or just did you sort of map it
out like how much did you map out did
you map out your whole career or no I
just I do it every every year every year
every year like I'd have like just right
I just write like I mean you know hey
your rugby box like I just I'd write
down like you're saying what I want to
achieve that year I just remember and
then
you have a pretty look like loose plan
but like
and um
it's like that kind of manifestation
stuff that Timmy talks about yeah
um but yeah like
like hard work just always takes care of
stuff eh yeah like literally I thought
so yeah
and you know if you're like the gun the
other way you know oh it's not quite
going to pain because I'm I'm not
working on that like taking a shitload
of shortcuts exactly yeah 100 percent
so then it's just like anything in life
whether it's rugby relationships
anything like just
work hard and good things happen so
right what a way to finish one of the
great podcasts
um absolute Legend obviously someone
I've followed uh very closely since my
um since you used to beat up since Oscar
rugby all those present cup questions
yours yeah like we hardly ever beat you
guys like when you text me and said I'll
start from press conference
we'll go from Friday
yeah but it has been awesome to go
through a journey um obviously
incredible career you've had um still
going I'm looking forward to what's next
but
um yeah absolute pleasure having you on
the podcast mate you're a true legend
thank you for having me on Jimmy nice to
connect these last couple of weeks and
thanks for the job you're doing here
yeah you're killing it man so keep it up
mate appreciate it absolutely Ed
[Music]
what an absolutely